just to remind you if your computers and
what have you searches up on Google will
be the first result let's go on today's
web site and it's a two page PDF that
it'll be good to refer to the second
we're moving into m2 there's actually
something in every one that I'm gonna
leave off for next week and I'll explain
why later so you remember we drew that
mind map yesterday and I left one of the
bubbles empty we'll come back to that in
due time but I want to do some of these
things under it up to which is if you
like you can write this down ever to is
applications of perimeter area and
volume applications all perimeter area
and no and you might have these back for
when we did the metric units of
measurement yeah these are about
one-dimensional two-dimensional and
three-dimensional space measurements
yeah so started with proven up now
previous super simple to begin with
which is why actually today we're gonna
do two exercises which is why I am and
they've got their review questions you
guys know I have this fixation our names
and that kind of theme meter is just
what you put on any word when you want
to measure something does anyone know
what is prefix Perry meets if you're not
the you have Portuguese food what kinds
of words do you have like carry in
submarines anyone some some reads what's
what a summer eat everything that's been
a pretty scary that a periscope plane
another one which admittedly is not that
common but it'll help you up as Hungary
in science nerd um the pericardium is a
part of your body it's um yeah that's
right it's a sheet that goes around your
heart actually and in fact that's what
Perry beans
it means around which is my periscope is
what helps you see around something
that's in your way okay so in its
perimeter that's why we measure around
an object that's all of it now for most
objects you're going to be with shapes
you envision triangles rectangles
quadrilaterals of any kind in fact
polygons that you could all you're doing
is you're just adding up all of the
links yeah the only important one that
seems a bit different to that is the
perimeter of a circle has a special name
right what's the previous Ethel mystic
conference so this is a conference the
length measured around a circle it's the
only one that's special because well it
doesn't have straight edges that I can
add up we have a formula for this and
it's on the formula data sheet which is
why I wanted you refresh so you don't
look for it if you ever look at that
does anyone remember what it is okay now
I'm just gonna take this opportunity to
even though it's not what we're looking
at today we are gonna look at is I hope
you take this opportunity to remind you
well the circumference formula and the
area formula are very very closely
related they look very similar easy to
confuse does anyone know yeah it's power
squared
now the helpful way that I have like I
mean you can see they are the same
numbers in them they just slightly
continue differently the way I remember
which one is which is that what you
think of that area right what kinds of
Units do we associate with areas like
square centimeters square meters square
whatever okay because you've got an area
so that's why the radius gets squared
it's for that exact purpose right so if
you think about area being is square
units you use the formula with the
square
and circumference is the yellow and of
course you can look up the form of the
datasheet but if you have it in your
memory if you can't remember then do it
because then you don't have to spend the
time to go and look it up so on our
diagram here right let's uh put on the
radius which therefore means if I you're
all the way around that's 2 pi that's my
circumference yeah now the other reason
why I want to mention it here the circle
being special not only doesn't have its
own formula but it also kind of has to
four minutes because sometimes you don't
know the radius or you're not given the
radius of a circle you're given
something else what might be another
name and I am annoyed yes so instead of
just cut back from the center to the
circumference
you get the whole measurement across so
if you have a dilemma what's the
relationship between the diode ax and
the radius the diameter is 2 times the
diameter is double the radius right so
you can see I actually have double the
radiance in my circumference formula
right so instead of writing 2 PI R you
could write or I've got a substitute
instead of 2 I'm just gonna write Diana
but let's call that D okay so instead of
2 and R I'm just going to write D so I
know there's a fine and obviously you
use whichever one based on whatever
information you're presenting ok